foreign
The Only Thing Worth stealing is the
kiss of a sleeping child
[Music]
for some of us happiness comes while we
sleep
the Potter sleeps soundly for no one
will steal clay
men and women sleep on the same pillow
but have different dreams
sleep is the Wish Your Heart Makes when
you are fast asleep
[Music]
Bree time is those five or six hours
when you sleep at night
your future depends on your dreams so go
to sleep
[Music]
is the golden chain that links Health to
your body
a good laugh and a long sleep are the
best medicines in the doctor's book
when I'm at work I can fall asleep
instantly but when I'm in my bed I can
hardly sleep
[Music]
if a person had as many ideas during the
day as during insomnia he would be rich
some people can't sleep because they
have insomnia I can't sleep because I
have internet
a sleeping Fox counts chickens in his
dream
happiness is waking up looking at your
watch and finding you have two more
hours of sleep
[Music]
your eyes water when you yawn because
you miss your bed and you feel sad
the soul of the righteous contemplates
the mysterious sky in a dream
our birth is just a dream and Oblivion
you know you're in love when you can't
sleep because reality is better than
your dreams
[Music]
never go to bed angry stay on your feet
and fight
every night when I go to bed I die and
the next morning when I wake up I am
Reborn
laugh and the whole world laughs with
you snore and you sleep alone
[Music]
even the soul immersed in sleep working
hard and helping make something out of
the world
[Music]
sleep is the most innocent creature
there is and a Sleepless man the
guiltiest
if you can't sleep get up and do
something instead of lying around and
worrying you get anxiety not insomnia
life is what happens when you can't
sleep
there are five main facts in life birth
food sleep Love and Death
sleep at odds with broken hearts there
will be nothing to do with them
the best cure for insomnia is to sleep a
lot
sleep is like a cat it only comes to you
if you ignore it
never waste time that you can spend
sleeping
everything seems possible at night when
the rest of the world is asleep
[Music]
is the single most effective thing we
can do to restore the health of our
brain and body
[Music]
fatigue is the safest sleeping pill
as important as it is to have a plan for
getting the job done perhaps even more
important is having a plan for rest
relaxation self-care and sleep
when you wake up with a song stuck in
your head it means that an angel has
been singing to you to fall asleep
always go to bed in cute pajamas you
never know who you will meet in your
dreams
[Music]
a dream is a skillful magician it
changes the proportions of things the
distances between them it separates
people as they lie side by side brings
them closer and they barely see each
other
both sleep and insomnia if they are
excessive are harmful
[Music]
in whatever disease sleep may be
difficult it is a deadly symptom but if
sleep is beneficial it is not fatal
[Music]
I really like it when a bad dream
doesn't scare you but inspires you
when things go wrong the strongest take
a nap
[Music]
no wonder Sleeping Beauty looked so good
she slept long never got old and didn't
have to do anything but snore to get her
prince charming
I always say morning instead of good
morning because if it were a good
morning I would still be sleeping
[Music]
don't give up on your dreams too early
sleep longer
a day without sleep is like a cupcake
without icing
[Music]
there is no day so bad that it cannot be
corrected by a good nap
[Music]
insomnia is a glamorous term for the
thoughts you forgot about during the day
I tried counting sheep to sleep
to sleep but it got boring so I started
talking to the shepherd instead
the best bridge between Despair and hope
is a good night's sleep
[Music]
when you lie down you will not be afraid
your sleep will be sweet
A well-spent Day brings a happy dream
[Music]
A Mother's Hands Are Made of tenderness
and a sweet dream blesses the child that
lies within
[Music]
people who say they sleep like a baby
usually don't have one
[Music]
joy and sorrow sleep in the same bed
babies smile in their sleep because they
listen to Angels whispering
there are hard days in motherhood but
the sight of a sleeping baby reminds you
why it's worth it
poor men sleep the best
silence is the sleep that nourishes
wisdom
sleep is the best meditation
people who snore always fall asleep
first
[Music]
he who sleeps on a silver bed dreams of
gold
[Music]
get up first in the morning and go to
bed last in the evening for those who
sleep do not catch fish
to fulfill a pipe dream try to fall
asleep
having sex with your ex in your dreams
can mean that you are feeling
unfulfilled in your current relationship
[Music]
a guard's dream is a thief's flashlight
the more you know the less you will
sleep
poverty is even worse if you have to
sleep on the edge of a cramped bed
[Music]
if a man threatens you sleeps soundly at
night
if it is a woman stay awake
[Music]
if you're going to do something tonight
that you will regret tomorrow morning
stay up late
[Music]